we will now go through an example that
involves a continuous unknown parameter
the unknown bias of a coin and discrete
observations namely the number of heads
that are observed in a sequence of coin
flips this is an example that we will
study in some detail now and we will
also revisit later on and in the process
we will also have the opportunity to
introduce a new class of probability
distributions this example is an
extension of an example that we have
already seen when we first introduced
the relevant version of the Bayes rule
we have a coin it has a certain bias
between 0 & 1 but the bias is unknown
and consistent with the Bayesian
philosophy we treat this unknown bias as
a random variable and we assign a prior
probability distribution to it we flip
this coin n times independently where n
is some positive integer and we record
the number of heads that are obtained on
the basis of the value of this random
variable we would like to make
inferences about theta now to make some
more concrete progress let us make a
specific assumption let us assume that
the prior on theta is uniform on the
unit interval in some sense reflecting
complete ignorance about the true value
of theta we observe the value of this
random variable some little K we fix
that value and we're interested in the
functional dependence on theta of this
particular quantity when K is given to
us how do we do this we use the
appropriate form of the Bayes rule which
in this setting is as follows it is the
usual form but we have F indicating
densities whenever we are talking about
the distribution of theta because theta
is continuous and whenever we talk about
the distribution of K which is discrete
we use the symbol P because we are
dealing with probability mass functions
as always the denominator term
is such that the integral of the whole
expression over theta is equal to 1 this
is the necessary normalization property
and because of this this denominator
term has to be equal to the integral of
the numerator over all theta which is
what we have here so now let us move and
let us apply this formula we first have
the prior which is equal to 1 then we
have the probability that K is equal to
little K this is the probability of
obtaining exactly K heads if I tell you
the bias of the coin but if I tell you
the bias of the coin were dealing with
the usual model of independent coin
flips and the probability of K heads is
given by the binomial probabilities
which takes this form and finally we
have the denominator term which we do
not need to evaluate at this point now I
said earlier that we're interested in
the dependence on theta which comes
through these terms on the other hand
the remaining terms do not involve any
Thetas and so they can be lumped
together in just a constant and so we
can write the answer that we have found
in this more suggestive form we have
some normalizing constant and here we
keep separately the dependence on theta
of course this answer that we derived is
valid for little theta belonging to the
unit interval outside the unit interval
either the prior density or the
posterior density of theta would be
equal to 0 this particular form of the
posterior distribution for theta is a
certain type of a density and it shows
up in various contexts and for this
reason it has a name it is called a beta
distribution with certain parameters and
the
rameters reflect the exponents that we
have up here in the two terms note that
these parameters are the exponents
augmented by one this is for historical
reasons that do not concern us here it
is just a convention the important thing
is to be able to recognize what it takes
for a distribution to be a beta
distribution that is the dependence on
theta is of the form theta to some power
times one minus theta
to some other power any distribution of
this form is called the beta
distribution so now let's continue this
example by considering a different prior
suppose that the prior is itself a beta
distribution of this form where alpha
and beta are some non-negative numbers
what is the posterior in this case we
just go through the same calculation as
before but instead of using one in the
place of the prior we now use the prior
that's given to us the probability of k
heads in the entosis when we know the
bias is exactly as before it is given by
the binomial probabilities and finally
we need to divide by the denominator
term which is the normalizing constant
what do we observe here the dependence
on theta comes through these terms the
remaining terms do not involve theta and
they can all be absorbed in a constant
let's call that constant D and collect
the remaining terms we have theta to the
power alpha plus K and then 1 minus
theta to the power of beta plus n minus
K
and once more this is the form of the
posterior for Thetas belonging to this
range the posterior is zero outside this
range so what do we see we started with
the prior that came from the beta family
of this form and we came up with a
posterior that is still a function of
theta of this form but with different
values of the parameters alpha and beta
namely alpha gets replaced by alpha plus
K beta gets replaced by beta plus n
minus K so we see that if we start with
a prior from the family of beta
distributions the posterior will also be
in that same family this is a beautiful
property of beta distributions that can
be exploited in various ways one of
which is that it actually allows for
recursive ways of updating the posterior
of theta as we get more and more
observations